every year you [ __ ] about everything  that you hate  and it's become a tradition every  [ __ ] year  that they put this montage together  about [ __ ] that you hate  yeah so here's the 20 20 montage here we  go  and i [ __ ] hate mosquitoes i just  hate halloween  my father hated it i hated it i hate  rush i mean it's not my thing but  even though i look like yeti lee i hate  going to a store i hate shopping  i hate that soap dish i knew that  [ __ ] soap dish was a problem but  where am i gonna put my soap next to the  sink i hate the iowa caucus [ __ ] hate  psychics because i hate anybody who  lies to people i hate that radio hall of  fame i hate these zoom conferences i  hate the name howard  i hate feeling human i don't know how  you guys do it wow  wow pretty pretty but that sums it up  wow  but i got to tell you what i really hate  i hate hearing what i hate  you